Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to the "Gauntlet Of Ire".
Now...
From what I've seen, and what I've been told, and what I've read about this game,
it's supposedly quite difficult.(sounds gentlemanly)
Now, I don't know how true that is, and I don't understand if it's going to be THAT bad...
But I wanted to give it a chance to see -
oh
easy mode or hard mode.
well I mean, what's the point of playing a rage game if you're not gonna play it in hard mode?
Oh, it's locked.
Oh, ok. So I got to do easy mode first.
Okay!
Alright.
"Idiot-proof"
Uh-huh. Okay! ...
Uh!
Oh!
Alright.
Well, this doesn't seem so bad.
It's a beautiful game! You gotta admit.
Okay... alright. A little -
Why did you slow down!?
Why -
Why'd you slow down?
Why would you have slowed down?
It's obviously not idiot-proof if i got through because I'm no idiot.
I'm no fool!
Uh huh...
Wait a minute...
oo
ee
uu
nOOOooooo
uh
Well ain't that a sack of shit, but that's alright. You know, I don't like the music going into this because it suggests...
...that I'm gonna go crazy.
Okay
Why is- no! What? Why is THAT like THAT? Why would that be like that?
Ok...
Yes, I know how to play.
I guess I don't necessarily need to land on all of them. I can jump over some.
Yeah!
ooo
Oooooh, so dicey. Wait, you're not like that now.
Oh there you are.
uu-NoOO!!!
AUGH! God! I just gotta jump over that. Alright, easy-peasy.
I know how to play the game. Thank you very much.
I feel like I'm in preschool. Like, something about the primary colors and the fact that
I'm rolling the ball down a...straightaway,
it all kind of bring back to the idea that I'm just an idiot child, and
I...DON'T...NOOOOO!!!
(ping of death)
What am I supposed to do???
How am I supposed to be able to make that jump?
Like am I actually supposed to get through this?
Why am I communist ball? (Really, Mark? -_-)  (So.. Everything Wrong With Gauntlet of Ire?)
That's the things that I don't understand about this...
Can the music please change? That's all I ask.
Just a little bit of variation between everything that I got going on.
whaAAaa
How are you supposed to get through that?
How are you supposed to get through that, huh?
I mean I could j-ehhh, I don't think I could jump over that.
Yes, "Idiot-proof", I'm aware. I'm an idiot, and it's not idiot-proof. I get it. (To be fair, Mark..)
It's...it's different. It IS different. It's different every time!
But only slightly!
Enough to infuriate you! Ooh, making the jump!
NOOOOO
....How uh....
..How would you do that?
No. No!
Why.. Why..? Wh- WHY!?
Why did you do that? Why did you do that? Why did you do that?
WHY?
Can I jump on my graves...? Is that something I could do? Can I dance on my own grave, please?
That's something that I'd much appreciate in this scenario.
If I could just....
uH..
..make this-YES! Why?
Because its different! ITS DIFFERENT!
Wait-
No!
WAIT!
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?!
IT'S DIFFERENT! You changed it!
You changed it... You made it random..
Why would you make it random?
That's the most infuriating thing that I- *DONG*
I-!!
What are- WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?!
What does 'get donged' mean?! Why would I 'get donged?' It's different!
Why are you different? Why is it different?
That doesn't make any sense! Usually its something that you could learn, and get better at, oh- *DONG*
I got donged...
Why don't I just jump over that?
Uuuh..
I can change while I'm jumping..
Okay.....alright...
Silly billy..
Uh oh.... (x2)
got ya, I got your number now
Oop- oopa doopa doopa doop...
Oopa doopa doopa doop...!
A-oopa doopa doopa doop!
Oop-
Uh oh uh oh uh oh- EURGH
Ah, too far! NO- not far enough!
(maniacal laughter)
I got you. I got ya got ya. I got ya. How would you be able to do that anyway?
Well of course you do this!
Stupid idiot. What do you think I am? Exactly what I said you were? Shut up, also! You're ugly, and I'm handsome!
I'm gonna jump on that...! I'm gonna drop on that...! Okay. We're good
Oh, I don't like- the visuals are breaking my brain!
I am..NOT GOOD!
There we go!
Easy peasey, lemon squeeze me!
'Training wheels come off.' Okay!
Impossible? Says you! "That's im-"
How-
Oh....
Wha...?
How...
What...What?!
What- what- how? What- how'd you-
This doesn't make any sense!
What'd you...
What'd you-
What are you talking about?!
Huh, ahh, just kill me! Kill me! Kill me!
Okay, all right, you know what? I don't get that, but okay.
All right, all right
Staying positive. I got this. I got this. Impossible? My left nut it's impossib- ohh...
Okay, I have goofed it. Whoa whoa whoa easy there, buddy boo get some speed... how about some speed
Huh? This is not blazing speed
I didn't mean to dong you, sorry, okay. It's fine
I got the recipe for fun times yes, I am a happy sack of shit
Oh, eurgh-
Just gonna go around
All of these assholes here, I did it yeah
I'm on the high ground and I have a light touch. It is really cool, and I like it!
Uh- oh, oh..
I don't like that. I really don't like that attack. I'm not gonna make it
I didn't make it....I'M ALIVE!
God Damnit
Okay here we go. I got this. It's a really cool game, and I hAVE A
really light touch I pet- oh fuck
Kitties with my touch and it is cool.
ugh
I am a good player of games
Here we go
I've FORGOT AGAIN OH SHIT ME YO! Oh god me yoI HOIMIE NOI
I'm not having fun. It is really cool to be in pain. Oh, it's a light touch.
I forgot about the light touch a-GAIN
Why can't I just be YOUR NEW FRIEND? Oh boy, it's not really cool. Oh boy light touch
oeiughhh
ouhhhu
That's not cool
That's also NOT COOL. I'm so fast. I'm so fast! Why am I so fast?
I made it. Gotta go fast. I was. Bite the pillow?
No?
No, I don't want to bite the pillow, no
That doesn't sound very fun to me. I'm going real fast. I don't like this
There was a little fast but I am fine
Baby, come back to me. I don't know..- what do you want?
Uh oh
Goin' real slow
No, no no no no no no no no no, where am I going? Wait. Wha-, why am I- why am I going backwards?
Wait, hey, wai- Hang on
Wai-
Wait. How the- That doesn't make any sense. Why would that happen?
What, why is this?
Why is this happening?
EURGH- Why is this happening??
Why, why are you doing this? Hey
Why're you doing this? Hey! Hey! Come on, what are you doing? NO
No, no no. No! What the- No! What are you doing?? OW!
I got donged! What the hell?? I don't know where I am. I don't know what is go-
How- um- uh...
How's that supposed to work, you know?
Oh boy
Oh, boy. Okay, and maybe I'm supposed to touch as little as possible?
I don't- I don't know... (light chuckling)
I don't know. I don't know how this is supposed to be done
Baby come back to me, baby come back
Please, it's different now. I'm different- No!
I've forgotten how to play...
Ooooh Light touch
Oooh, yeah
Oh yeah...
OH YEAH
Come on. I'm almost there, I'm so close! Come on!
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
Please, yes, yes, yes, yes
I did it. I am making things worse now? Yes? I don't want to do that, that sounds real bad
WOOOH
AUHHH
REALITY IS SHIFTING ON ME
Ooooh
God, oh god. Oh god. Oh god
Okay
Yes, I got a lot of things in my-
Why. No, please don't do that to me. Oh no no no, no, I just got you. NO, I DONGED!
Ah shi
You're not straight...
why are you not-
why are you not straight anymore? Why-
ha hah..
it doesn't make any no no how
this is not
AH
Don't dong me, bro. Why am I going this wa
NoooooooooOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Okay....
I guess...? I don't want to take the scenic route. No. No I don't I don't want to do it
I just don't want to do it
eugh
(DONG)
no..
uh-uh..
This is great. Great just the way it is. Oh yeah...
Oh yeah..
ah- oH yeah
Oh Yeah
eaAAAHHHHHH
NO COME ON I WAS RIGHT THERE
God damn it
Huh fuck. me. in. the. butt.
I am really saucy in my hands, and I will not be denied
I am the man. I am the one that will beat your ass
Into the grass and I will win yes
Okay, oh
oh be doh
Oh
oh
Okay, I don't like nO NO NO! I was right there. God damn it! God damn it,
DAMN IT! (damn it!)
Okay, I got this, I got this. This is fully fine
Hoh boy
NO
pft, fucking god damn it.... I had it I didn't have it that time, but I really had it I
I have this. The scenic route is full of bullshit
But that does not mean that I won't be the guy who's got it NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
I will play...
This game until the day that I die! I just want to get through this one level
It's not that bad, I don't think so I won't be dead
cuz I am the man who will get the head.. uh uh
I can explain myself...
oh fuck...
Here we go
Again, it's time to go on with the show. I don't know what to do with my li- NO
EURGHHHH
ohhh god
(laughter)
oh no no..
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no...
Oh boy this is gonna make me lose my sanity
Ah, it's such a simple game though
Pleasant, one might say if they were stupid. Why does it have to be random? I don't know...
I don't know the developer chose this
This is a feature
Did you know this is a feature guys?
AUGH
No, no, I'm fine. I'm fine. I am- NO! I DONGED! I was fine. I was fine. I was fine
I was fine,
I was fine
Everything was going great in my life. I don't even have a wife
It is just strife in my life
Oh
Good now
I can't wait to get that big brown cow I hope I get a lot of beans when I
Exchange it for a bean stalk, my name is Steve. Oh God
EUGH
I am whispering, because I don't want to die...
Okay. Yes. Almost gonged that one
..yes..
ah, ah
Yes, yes, yes, yes! "Leap of Faith". No, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO! I don't want to do this...
(Screams)
Oh my God. I'm dead.
I don't wanna play this game. I don't wanna do anything-...
Uh! I gonged! (screams)
how do you
Do this level I don't really know now. I don't understand what to do
It's not real fair its not fair its not fair
That's not g- oohhhhh. Nope.
ok...
ok
Okay...
Oh, I gonged... it's okay...
AHH
euAH
no, NOOOOOOO
All right
I'm done. Nope. No no no nope nope nope nope nope I'm going home
So that was "Gauntlet of Ire"
Not impossible. I didn't get that far... but...
Oh... my god. Oh my- oh my god. There's so many levels
Nope nope nope not gonna do it. So I'm gonna leave that one there, if you guys want to see more than this, let me
know down in the comments below. I think I'm up to the challenge
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye Bye!